so we have a trailer for a happy
deathday to you this is beyond the truth
hi guys Greg here Donald maybe you
watched our reaction for happy that day
to you yay you know what I feel that
there's actually plenty of things to
talk about in this trailer you think
like it's happy deathday sequel what
would you really talk about this is the
definition of expanding universe
expanding upon something that was just a
cute little fun horror comedy idea and
now they're going in some whole new
direction that I don't like the trailer
took me out an interesting experience
because the first part of it was okay
you just if no one has seen happen I
know that it's a trailer sequel but if
no one has seen the first happy deathday
you have it completely ruined everything
you the mystery is not a mystery yeah I
feel like they could have just said what
the plot was it happened in happy
deathday and that she defeated it yeah
that would have ruined it with even like
go so far as to say and it ready to be
my roommate I'm like that's the big
final twist of the movie yeah like a
spoiler warning on the front there's
something instead of the red band of the
green yeah because that like well you
really don't need to watch the first one
which is like a pro and a con in some
ways you know yeah that was a funny
thing about some of the speculation as
to why this trailer took so long to get
onto the internet cuz it dropped with
Halloween originally and some people
were speculating like oh oh maybe
they're gonna take out the parts that
spoil the first movie and that is
evidently not sure yeah well that's
funny because I think you did the same
thing I went to go watch Halloween the
second the trailers like the very split
second it started I had popcorn and I
and I like my girlfriend I don't I had
to just like text early tell me when
this trailer is over reaction for it
this actually kind of caught me off
guard because at first I was a little
fused here I thought like they were
switching the protagonists all together
first oh yeah I thought it was gonna be
Ryan fun at the very top of it and I was
like that's interesting did you wanna
watch I mean he was kind of just funny
then they got a little more confusing
because like wait a minute it's such an
experience and present her again and
then it seems like are we going lazy now
we're just going back to the first movie
that I didn't initially alike what they
were doing when I was watching the
trailer but then towards the end of it
was when I started realizing oh they're
gonna like really try to explain what's
going on now they're gonna try to
explain whatever lore mysterious
supernatural entity your cursor I don't
know that's what I mean it's actually
got me curious about they don't really
throw that in your face in an
expositional way but get images in here
that could show it like what she's in
the plane jumping out on with a bikini
oh yeah that really hints at a much
bigger expansion of the unit yeah that
was a real halo jump they did she's the
first actress to jump in a baby that
high up you know really going after that
Tom Cruise what is know what is that
moment I don't know what that moment is
that's the thing about this trailer is
this trailer both confused and intrigued
me yeah because it definitely looks like
they are going to expand on just the
nature of what the day is I mean the
first movie is pretty whimsical and it
feels very much like a groundhog day
kind of thing whereas this feels like it
might go into some kind of I think you
brought this up some kind of like
parallel universe or like multiple
universes theory of some kind well yeah
because they had that whole science
laugh thingy experiment yeah with that
laser device yeah rather like if she's
like circling around it and then you
know it looked like very okay and then
they had that you know slow-motion Iron
Man shot whoo yeah like an Iron Man 3
when they're flying back and they have
this similar shot here so it seems like
they're going to even more stylish with
this one with their deaths which is part
of the fun of it and went back to the
universe thing they had to Ryan Fonz at
one point there has to be it seems like
they're teasing like the big face reveal
whoo that's gonna be just gonna be her
from another universe you know like
baby's gonna my god from it maybe it's
gonna be like the one with Jet Li where
she's going to all the others is killing
herself so that she could just get more
and more powerful each time I'm not sure
where this movie is it what's funny is
it seems like the first half is probably
just gonna feel like a giant retread of
the first one you know like okay set up
look at my life now it's so good
everything's good and then oh bam an act
- she's back - do you know the first
movie look how fun it is of her doing
The Hangover two things all over again
oh my god this is annoying and then we
get to that point in the movie where
you're like is this just gonna be the
same the whole time yeah and other
people are dying and I got maybe other
in the middle the stakes are higher
because more people are dying I guess
that was what I was ultimately able to
pick out as like everyone's experiencing
this deja vu or this like relived day
now but apparently it seems like she's
the only one who can actually reset the
day each time so like if other people
die they just die but if she dies the
day resets or something
yeah like I almost wondered if maybe
they put this out of order so that when
it first happens it'll be her waking up
into that day and then maybe the second
time Ryan will come in and be like wait
a minute now I remember the day yeah you
know like something like that
it's a strange expansion on it because I
kind of like that because now the stakes
are about more than just her living yeah
because it seems like she can make it to
tomorrow edge of tomorrow but anytime
she dies she just goes back yeah
and in order for everyone to have it
tomorrow so they're all banning together
so now it's more it's gonna be more of
an ensemble movie yeah that's just her
movie I think is an interesting
expansion on it because the first movie
was directed by Christopher Landon it
had a different screenwriter and now
that screenwriter is gone because a
screenwriter was probably like what the
hell else can you really do with this
guy this is the perfect contained one
off oh I do this and now Christopher
Landon is writing and directing this one
yeah so bringing that Paranormal
Activity yeah clearly there's like the
description of happy deathday to you who
thought a baby sequel to the 2013 Oh
not reveal any completely contrary it
seems like it'll be going crazier it
seems like it's gonna be having more fun
I'm kind of wondering you know sometimes
when you do these these pieces where
when you really start to explain or
enhance upon on you know the the
explanations of how the day's reset like
edge of tomorrow did it pretty well but
that was in the first movie that
explains what's going on like Groundhog
Day doesn't do it happy deathday doesn't
do it it's just a piece you you kind of
just accept and I'm wondering if they
explain it will that take away from it
you know what I mean yeah III it all
comes down to their idea you know I feel
like easily go both ways it could easily
be something where you're like oh you
just wanted to have a sequel cuz this
made money or they could have something
really clever up their sleeve I mean I
like some of the hints I'm getting and
this is one of those trailers that
really gives me the impression that this
could easily go either way
yeah and I'm I hope that they nail it
because the first happy deathday like
was a pleasant surprise for me even
having heard things about it going in I
just yeah I had a really fun time with
that movie and I feel like expanding on
it with the tone that they established
could really work yeah they have the
right idea and I like that they're maybe
gonna go down some kind of scientific
alternate universe or some prior I'm
pulling time theory like if we're gonna
do it you might as well put in the
effort for something like that you know
and I do love Jessica Roth's performance
in the first one she's I was I was on
movie fights just yesterday and I did
not argue this but uh I was on movie
fights a couple times ago and one of the
questions about it was who I think
should play the next Supergirl and I
argued that I think Jessica Roth would
be perfect for it
my choice I'm choosing Jessica Roth she
recently starred in the movie happy look
at that she could totally be Supergirl
especially because of the first happy
deathday movie granted I mean she looks
amazing she's got a great body she's
beautiful wildly talented actress but
she does look like the only one who is
not college age-appropriate anymore
you you look like it like a real adult
yeah everyone else still looks like a
college kid that's because I think a
real life is like 31 or something 30
yeah I mean she looks good for the
butcher 31 for sure but compared to our
old samba Kasim you look older than all
of them yeah yeah I hope they don't beat
this idea to death I think you just got
a if anything ended here but yeah this
looks fun last six movies I didn't think
you could really expand it the first
half that show that got me a little
worried that it was just gonna be a
giant repeat and but then as it kept
going I'm like okay you guys are gonna
do some weird exploration with this
which makes me very curious but yeah
well um house seems to be at least good
at that coming back with a sequel that
tries to do something more than ever so
I'll remain cautiously optimistic on
this well guys what do you think of
happy deathday to you looking forward to
it you excited comment below you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and hey check us
out patreon TV show reactions Q&A is
music video coverage we love to have you
become a project today
you